[Music]
when I started thinking about this
almost all my associations with aging or
older and where my fear was deepest had
to do with cognition dementia is a
terrifying disease and we are nowhere
near a cure I think what people forget
is that it is in no way typical of aging
the statistics the latest statistics
from the Alzheimer's Association and
this statistic has dropped significantly
just in the ten years I've been studying
is it is that one out of ten of the
entire sixty five-plus population does
come down with Alzheimer's the older you
are the more likely you are to get at
age is the biggest risk factor so the
percentage increases as you get older
but very very few people my age 66 have
Alzheimer's the point being it is not
typical of aging and telling both sides
of the story here Alzheimer's rates
continue to decline we're not sure why
but the odds of anyone listening to this
coming down with Alzheimer's have gotten
lower and lower and people are getting
diagnosed at later ages so let's tell
both sides of the story as we age most
of us do experience some decline in
specific cognitive functioning like the
ability to remember the name of that
movie you saw with what's-her-name last
week but one thing I'm always pointing
out to people is that younger people
forget stuff - all the time right this
is not just an old age of fliction where
ageism comes in is that when you can't
remember the name of the movie and
you're my age you think oh crap that
means I'm getting dementia which it
might but it really really really
probably does not it is true that older
people can take longer to come to a
conclusion about something or perhaps
remember something but one reason this
is so and interesting this came out of a
study done by data science scientists in
Germany who weren't even studying
anything aging related is that as we
grow older we acquire more experiences
and memories so literally just like a
processor the brain has to sift through
more information to get to an answer and
is that process of sifting that enables
us often older people to come up with a
more measured or deeper respond
that's why it is so terrific to have
mixed age teams for many reasons that
are intuitively obvious younger people
might come up with more answers more
quickly and possibly think of things
that an older more perhaps you know
experienced person might think oh we
tried that 10 years ago and it's not
going to work but you if you pair the
agility of a young mind with the
experience of a and more seasoned
approach of an older worker you arrive
at a synthesis that is the best possible
thing you can make an analogy in terms
of physical activity as well older
workers certainly physically move slower
no doubt about that but they injured
themselves less often a growing body of
really really interesting evidence shows
how attitudes towards aging affect how
our minds and bodies function at the
cellular level people with more positive
attitudes towards aging which I would
say is simply more realistic attitudes
towards aging because most of us are so
brainwashed to equate aging with decline
show that they walk faster they have
better handwriting which is a pretty
good indicator of general health they
heal faster even from severe disability
they live longer not just a little bit
an average of seven and a half years
longer and the latest Reacher's research
shows that positive attitudes towards
aging confer protection against dementia
even in people genetically predisposed
to the disease the idea is that if you
are not worrying about aging if you are
not under this stress of believing that
everything is going to go to hell in a
handbasket and you are going to be
conferred to the sort of dustbin of
history or abandoned by those you love
or abandoned by your brain or deserted
by your body those are all sources of
stress they are messages that an ageist
culture bombard us with right and on a
daily basis in the news starting with
children's books all the way up when we
refute those messages when we look at at
the purpose behind them and look at the
evidence all around us at the lives that
older people are living it's very easy
to see the the alternate truthful
reality and that confers protection the
earlier in life we become what I call an
old person in training
which is to acknowledge that guess what
we're gonna come become old and it's
probably gonna be different than we
think right now and probably way better
the better because then we can see a
gist messages in the culture more
clearly and refute them if we look
around at the older people around us it
is obvious that the vast majority are
living interesting lives and going about
their daily lives with interest and
purpose I have never met anyone who
actually wanted to be any younger no
matter how terrified they were of
getting older so think about that right
because even if we are brainwashed by an
ageist culture we know that our years
are what make us us
[Music]